now to present the award to the best
picture former Academy Award winner miss
Audrey Hepburn hello Audrey how are you
darling very nice seeing you again dia
Jerry yes before I present the award I
have something for you
for me I don't figure to get one of them
all right it's not quite an Oscar but
for your wonderful work tonight the
Board of Governors of the Academy have
asked me to give you this that's yeah
that's very nice and I certainly
appreciate it I can't wait to get home
to see if it fits on the mantel
and now the nominees for best picture of
the year love is a many-splendored thing
20th Century Fox produced by buddy Adler
Marty Hecht Lancaster United Artists
produced by Harold Hecht
mr. Roberts Warner Brothers produced by
Leland Hayward picnic Columbia produced
by Fred Kramer the roaster - Hal Wallis
paramount produced by Hal B Wallis the
winner is Marty
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you it's very fortunate to live in
a country where any man no matter how
humble its origin can become president
and to be part of an industry or any
picture no matter how low its budget can
win the Oscar all of us who worked on
Marty especially fortunate for this
great honor for to us all from the very
beginning it was a labor of love thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations Thank You Audrey ladies
and gentlemen we would like to stay
right here and now you've been more than
a wonderful audience but I have a wee
bit of a speech to make myself I
sincerely hope that you will take it
from the spirit in which it's meant
about 15 years ago I had the good
fortune of working at Louis State
Theatre in New York on the third aisle I
was an usher and I watched many many
motion pictures that came out of
Hollywood that starred some of the
performance around the stage tonight I
was very very thrilled to be a part of
this and I am very very thrilled and
very grateful that you sat still for my
nonsense and sat still for the fact that
I was performing in a different element
so to speak we've been very very nice
into the television audience we
sincerely hope that we'll have the good
fortune of seeing you all again sometime
in person we hope that you'll go to the
movies very often we want you to enjoy
television of course but movies are
better than ever and we want you to know
that the entertainment capital of
America which is Hollywood hopes that we
can continue to make the motion pictures
that will make you happy on behalf of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences I would like to thank miss
Claudette Colbert in New York mr.
Colbert thank you very much for a very
wonderful job
congratulations Jerry you're the cutest
thank you thank you very much Claudette
that's awfully nice did you say this but
my wife is in the audience and she's
Italian and she hits like a head would
have break and all but I would like very
much to get one real wonderful round of
applause for gentlemen who did a
magnificent job in putting the show on
tonight with all his help and all the
wonderful people and his staff the
president of the Motion Picture Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences mr.
George Seaton ladies and gentlemen
thank you and Gerry thank you for your
tremendous contribution of the Academy
may I thank mr. Dolan mr. Shea volson
mr. Rose mr. Breen mr. Previn and
everyone else and especially the Academy
staff was been up night and day for the
last two weeks god bless them all see
you next year thank you ladies ladies
and gentlemen could we have the house
lights please alik electrician thank you
very much we might as well play the
overture mr. Previn entertainment we'd
like all of you here in the Pantages
Theater to walk out to a very pretty
melody that's entertainment do you have
it up mr. Previn you might as well play
it it's very pretty
all of you go home and have a good
night's rest we will look forward to
seeing you again next year hit if it's
beautiful when I talk with music good
night Hollywood thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the annual awards of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences have
been brought to you by your old mobile
dealer you're cordially invited to tune
in Saturday April 14th special news the
presentation of The Adventures of Marco
Polo dyeing Alfred Drake in Zulueta
Morrow and brought to you by your own
mobile dealers musical supervision by
Bobby Helper
now this is Frank Barton bidding you
good night from Hollywood
[Music]